good afternoon lieutenant david valenta
visa and victor a-l-e-n-t-a lieutenant
with the homicide sex crimes bureau with
the las vegas metropolitan police
department here to brief you today on an
ongoing homicide investigation
started earlier just before 2 pm this
afternoon when metro police received the
call of a person that had been shot
petroleum paramedics arrived in the 900
block of morgan
at which time they did find a male
suffering from an apparent gunshot wound
life-saving measures were attempted but
the victim was ultimately pronounced
deceased on the scene
detectives homicide detectives then been
called and responded taking over the
investigation
at this time everything's still very
preliminary
ongoing canvassing talking to witnesses
talking to victims
talking to anyone else who may have
information
possibly looking for a black male
suspect with dreads
absolutely looking for public assistance
on this anyone with any information that
may know something may have seen
something here's something
please contact las vegas metropolitan
police you can remain anonymous calling
crime stoppers at
contact 385-5555 homicide at homicide
lvmpd.com
with that i'll take any questions
any other indication of what led to this
happening
right now very preliminary just unknown
altercation right now
seems to be a fairly isolated incident
again looking for any public assistance
right in front of the residence on the
900 block
uh we don't give out that information
uh if i knew that it'd be a lot farther
down the
age or anything investigation that with
the victim or the suspect the the victim
is a 29 year old male
uh suspect very little right now other
than possibly a black male with
dreadlocks
we're talking to everybody right now um
we'll put everything together and see
where it goes again very early right now
just starting to talk to everybody
victim is not believed to live in the
area
i can't say for sure right now i know
for sure once uh we wait for the coroner
to come and we'll be able to do the full
body exam and give me definitive answers
on that thank you very much